while the trump administration continues
to hold up the transition
president-elect biden's team is
considering legal action of their own
and it comes at a crucial moment for the
country
on issues like the pandemic
president-elect biden announced his new
coronavirus task force yesterday
and our ed o'keefe is following all of
it ed good morning to you
what do we know about these potential
legal challenges from the biden team
oh good morning tony from delaware by
law the biden transition office has been
open since the summer but now it's
supposed to be getting
broader access to federal agencies since
mr biden is now president-elect
so far trump administration officials
are holding back and that comes as the
biden team is making its own plans to
tackle the coronavirus pandemic
following the launch of his new
coronavirus task force president-elect
joe biden urged americans to stop the
spread of coronavirus by wearing a mask
do it for yourself do it for your
neighbor
a mask is not a political statement
biden was briefed on the positive early
results of pfizer's coronavirus vaccine
trial
and while he praised the news he said
wearing masks and social distancing
remained critical it's clear that this
vaccine even if approved
will not be widely available for many
months yet to come
the challenge before us right now is
still immense and growing
in addition to the pandemic the biden
harris transition is also preparing to
fill more than 4
000 positions across the federal
government but the transition office is
being blocked from full access to
federal agencies
by emily murphy a trump appointee who
leads the general services
administration
that handles the logistics of a
transition gsa has said murphy will only
grant biden's team full access
and funding once she ascertains a winner
is clear
based on the process laid out in the
constitution
responding to reporter questions late
monday a biden harris transition
official told reporters
that if the gsa doesn't act soon there
are a number of options on the table
legal action is certainly a possibility
but there are other options as well
that we're considering so far just four
republican senators have congratulated
the president-elect
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
isn't one of them and president trump
is 100 within his rights to look into
allegations of irregularities
and weigh his legal options but at the
same time he's so doubt on the
presidential election results
mcconnell praised congressional results
all of which
were on the same ballots according to
preliminary results voters across the
nation
elected and reelected republican
senators to a degree
that actually stunned prognosticators
now republican senators mitt romney and
marco rubio are among those calling on
gsa to give mr biden
broader access to agencies now that the
transition is underway
romney says that the biden team deserves
it because of national security reasons
and rubio says
that allowing the biden team to begin
visiting federal agencies and doing the
work it needs to do
wouldn't impede the president's ongoing
legal challenges gales one of the
reasons that this matters
is really for national security purposes
among other things the biden transition
team at this point should be getting
classified briefings access to secure
facilities
the ability to submit more names for
background briefings they can't even
talk to the state department yet
to help them facilitate the calls that
they're getting from world leaders to
congratulate mr biden so
it's a bit of a mess one that they hope
gets cleaned up in the coming days
you said it's a bit of a mess that
continues to grow thank you very much ed